natürlich
do
nein nein nein du bist schon etwas platt
herz bekommen weil neuen video
ich hoffe das ist okay so hier von der
location weil ich was am strand die
scheiße war dagegen ballack der menschen
warum auch immer und ich habe mein
mikrofon vergessen das ist ein bisschen
windig deswegen bin ich jetzt hier und
macht hier ein neues video für euch ihr
habt mir mal wieder zahlreiche fragen
gestellt hoffe ich muss jetzt durch
nachgucken und die werden von mir
beantwortet ich bin mir gerade im urlaub
auf der insel formentera das ist im
mittelmeer spanien ich weiß nich kennt
ihr das hier könnte man die kommentare
schreiben interessiert mich wirklich
weil wir sind irgendwie kaum jugendliche
deutsche deswegen bin ich schon mal hier
warten oder so oder wenn es kein
schreibt es auf jeden fall mal die
kommentare
ich war gerade wie ihr gesehen habt noch
mehr deswegen sind meine haare heute
nicht so perfekt wie sonst aber ich
finde es ist ok auf jeden fall ja am
nächsten sonntag hoffe ich kommt noch
ein krasses video von ihr also ich habe
mir einige coole aufnahmen gemacht das
habe ich gut zusammen geschnitten und
deswegen kommt dass sonntag irgendwann
online ich hoffe ihr feiert das deswegen
freut euch sonntag auf ein cooles video
von mir und jetzt würde ich sagen wir
lieber gar nicht lange fangen einfach
mal ein paar fragen zu beantworten
ich habe mal wieder bock drauf und mal
sehen die erste frage kommen von emily
und sie fragt wo möchtest du später mal
leben ja ich weiß ich kann es nicht
beurteilen finde ich aber ich finde so
spanien vor allem diese inseln hier
formentera details genau hier neben
mallorca vielleicht nicht so unbedingt
jetzt krabbeln irgendwas den füßen
aber ich find das vom klima hier einfach
richtig geil und so der sommer ist
einfach richtig schön deswegen ich würde
gern irgendwo hier glaube ich mal eben
es kann natürlich sein dass ich dann
nach einem halben jahr sage es ist
scheiße hier weil so lange leben hier
will ich nicht mehr zurück nach
deutschland kann ich nicht sagen aber
ich würde erstmal hier entziehen
irgendwie und jetzt kommt schon wieder
was war nämlich verraten
möchtest du kinder und wenn welches
geschlecht wie viele wie wird sie heißen
also natürlich möchte ich mal kinder
haben
am liebsten würde ich so einrichten
sollte seinen jungen wie sich das jetzt
an hört am liebsten will ich dann
richtig coolen süßen jungen machen also
wirklich so ein junge der cooles so der
der sich kulant sie so was finde ich
immer richtig cool also ich stelle mir
vor so einem süßen kleinen jungen zu
haben
den würde ich würde ich den nennen war
keine ahnung timo timo finde ich ist ein
cooler nature nicht ich weiß es nicht
man keine ahnung irgendwie würde ich dir
wohin genau oder so kennt ihr das
pokemon wohin genau das war immer mein
lieblingsbuch und nächste frage kommt
von momo würdest du manchmal lieber
unberührt seien also ich will mich jetzt
nicht als berühmt bezeichnen erstmal
klar es ist in manchen situationen ist
es wirklich cool so ich sag mal einige
vorteile zu haben
aber in anderen situationen so wenn man
halt angesprochen wird auf das von
irgendwelchen menschen die man nicht
kennt ist es manchmal richtig cool aber
manchmal kann es halt auch doof sein
wenn man irgendwie in dieser situation
das überhaupt nicht will aber mal was
will man machen so ich will halt auch
nie unfreundlich sein deswegen ihr könnt
mich immer ansprechen aber braucht meine
füße alter gut das bier verleiten aber
meine füße ich jetzt hier so unbequem
deswegen ich bin zufrieden so wie es
gerade ist und man hat sich dafür
entschieden deswegen ist es so ich kann
es nicht mehr ändern
ich will jetzt so viel wie möglich damit
erreichen ja genau nicht zu fragen
würdest du dir gern mal ein foto machen
und wenn ja wo also zuerst kann ich
sagen tattoos finde ich richtig geil so
ein versuch finde ich cool und mehrere
dann irgendwie nicht mehr so cool als
wenn ich mir jetzt machen würde wäre das
garantiert hier aber dafür muss ich erst
mal ein bisschen ins fitnessstudio gehen
also ich finde wenn tattoo dann sollte
man auch ein bisschen oberarme haben
sage ich mal
und irgendwie bin ich schon wieder
unbequeme auf jeden fall soll das hier
in oder hier in irgend was cool ist muss
auch nicht zu groß sein sondern eher
klein
das ding ist halt nur meine mutter ist
so voll dagegen deswegen mache ich es
vielleicht jetzt noch nicht aber dann in
zwei drei wochen oder vielleicht auch
erst in zwei jahren bist du gerade so
zufrieden mit seinem leben oder willst
du was ändern also ich bin eigentlich
gerade voll zufrieden ich meine ich hab
richtig viel freizeit kann das machen
was mir spaß macht
ich werde jetzt erst nächstes jahr
anfangen mit dem studium deswegen stelle
ich gerade mein leben und mal gucken was
so alles passiert ich habe jetzt noch
sehr viel sommer vor mir richtig geile
zeit wir das hoffentlich und ich habe
einfach bock drauf so viel wie möglich
raus zu machen deswegen bin ich zurzeit
wirklich sehr zufrieden
auch meine wunderschöne freundin bin ich
sehr zufrieden mit die ist halt so kann
man schon zufrieden
viel spaß
ich lasse es einfach wir machen weiter
mit der nächsten frage so leute nächste
frage die wollte ich auch auf jeden fall
noch beantworten und zwar ich bin ja
hier auf formentera eben schon gesagt
das ist neben ibiza und zwei leute haben
mich gefragt wo genau bist du auf
formentera oder in formentera das heißt
auf formentera formentera ist ein insel
also auf jetzt bin ich fast umgefallen
auf jeden fall bin ich hier player
medion warte hier schon mal das ist ja
hier auf der nordseite keine ahnung im
norden geht die sonne geht die sonne auf
ja ich bin hier am player mit jahren und
hier gibt der strand hier ist nicht so
schön aber auf der anderen seite der
strand ist bombastisch das werdet ihr
aufsehen im video sonntag deswegen seid
gespannt
und jetzt geht gerade die sonne weg weil
da das frage ich mich immer genau wenn
ich ein video drehen will sie natürlich
wolken auf ihr sonst sich eine sonne
eine wolke
hier sind sich eine wolke und im
schatten sind es 35 grad und jetzt
kommen wollten alles klar dann würde ich
sagen ich beende das video hier mit ich
hoffe es hat euch gefallen wenn ja ihr
könnt mir gerne bei ich muss mich jetzt
auf jeden fall hinstellen check mir auf
jeden fall weitere fragen in die
kommentare und lassen dort nach oben da
bands durchgefallen als deutschland
instagram könnt ihr mir gerne folgen da
sind coole sachen zurzeit im umlauf weil
ich ja im urlaub bin und coole fotos und
snaps machen kann deswegen check das auf
jeden fall mal ab ja wir sehen uns dann
am sonntag wieder verpasst dieses video
auf keinen fall das wird wirklich cool
ich freue mich drauf und ich sage mal
drei leute